[Music]
the Heisenberg uncertainty principle is
one of a handful of ideas from quantum
physics to expand into general pop
culture it says that you can never
simultaneously know the exact position
and the exact speed of an object and
shows up as a metaphor in everything
from literary criticism to sports
commentary uncertainty is often
explained as a result of measurement
that the act of measuring an object's
position changes its speed or vice versa
the real origin is much deeper and more
amazing the uncertainty principle exists
because everything in the universe
behaves like both a particle and a wave
at the same time in quantum mechanics
the exact position and exact speed of an
object have no meaning to understand
this we need to think about what it
means to behave like a particle or a
wave particles by definition exist in a
single place at any instant in time we
can represent this by a graph showing
the probability of finding the object at
a particular place which looks like a
spike 100% at one specific position and
zero everywhere else waves on the other
hand our disturbances spread out in
space like ripples covering the surface
of a pond we can clearly identify
features of the wave pattern as a whole
most importantly its wavelength which is
the distance between two neighboring
Peaks or two neighboring valleys but we
can't assign it a single position it has
a good probability of being in lots of
different places wavelength is essential
for quantum physics because an object's
wavelength is related to its momentum
mass times velocity a fast moving object
has lots of momentum which corresponds
to a very short wavelength a heavy
object has lots of momentum even if it's
not moving very fast which again means a
very short wavelength this is why we
don't notice the wave nature of everyday
objects if you toss a baseball up in the
air its wavelength is a billionth of a
trillionth of a trillionth of a meter
far too tiny to ever detect small things
like atoms or electrons though can have
wavelengths big enough to measure in
physics experiments so if we have a pure
wave we can measure its wavelength and
thus its momentum but it has no position
we can know a particles position very
well but it doesn't have a wavelength so
we don't know its momentum to get a
particle with both position and momentum
we need to mix the two pictures to make
a graph that has waves but only in a
small area how can we do this by
combining waves with different
wavelengths which means giving our
quantum object some possibility of
having different momenta when we add two
waves we find that there are places
where the peaks line up making a bigger
wave and other places where the peaks of
one fill in the valleys of the other the
result has regions where we see waves
separated by regions of nothing at all
if we add a third wave the regions where
the waves cancel out get bigger a fourth
and they get bigger still with the wavy
regions becoming narrower if we keep
adding waves we can make a wave packet
with a clearer wavelength in one small
region that's a quantum object with both
wave and particle nature but to
accomplish this we had to lose certainty
about both position and momentum the
position isn't restricted to a single
point there's a good probability of
finding it within some range of the
center of the wave packet and we made
the wave packet by adding lots of waves
which means there's some probability of
finding it with a momentum corresponding
to any one of those both position and
momentum are now uncertain and the
uncertainties are connected if you want
to reduce the position uncertainty by
making a smaller wave packet you need to
add more waves which means a bigger
momentum uncertainty if you want to know
the momentum better you need a bigger
wave packet which means a bigger
position uncertainty that's the
Heisenberg uncertainty principle first
stated by German physicist Werner
Heisenberg back in 1927 this uncertainty
isn't a matter of measuring well or
badly but an inevitable result of
combining particle and wave nature the
uncertainty principle isn't just a
practical limit on measurement it's a
limit on what properties an object can
have built into the fundamental
structure of the universe itself
you
[Music]